Oh Bob we're seeing people from both
sides of the aisle calling on the
President to back down we're seeing
business leaders from a pro-business
president we're seeing business leaders
come out and openly disagree with what
happened on Friday what are your
thoughts on on this executive order and
whether it has teeth I mean obviously it
caused disruption well it's certainly
very disruptive the irony is it was
meant to improve the security and the
safety of Americans I don't think it
will do that one of the things you learn
from police chiefs in New York and
elsewhere is cooperation with the Muslim
community in this country is very
important to identifying security
threats from the Muslim community or
elsewhere second we need to work with in
for instance erupt a lot of people
translators and others and we've turned
our back on them in this order it's been
very disruptive to a lot of people
who've relied on the United States third
we want to develop a stronger coalition
with Muslims in the Arab world and
elsewhere this in a way works exactly
against that goal so it doesn't really
strengthen national security it weakens
it and also American principles American
values are a very important part of
American strength in the world or the
thing that enables other countries to
look at the United States and emulate
the United States and support the United
States if we compromise our values which
this does in a variety of ways the
statue of liberty is sort of the icon
American values these kinds of things
really undermine our credibility amongst
other democracies and throughout the
world so there has been a lot of please
to the emotions of people and so forth
and a lot of references to the Statue of
Liberty and various speeches that
previous presidents have given in this
no doubt that it was an extraordinarily
disruptive action to have taken on
friday afternoon at five thirty but
what's more perhaps surprising is how
little the agencies that were supposed
to carry it out knew about it before and
as
was happening have you ever been in a
situation where a country was so
unprepared for an action no and I think
that is really one of the problems had
they consulted Homeland Security the
State Department the Defense Department
the Justice Department in a thorough way
had they vetted it with the experts
there they would have learned that our
immigration laws are very complicated
they had no clear idea of whether it
applied to green card holders of how it
applied or whether it applied to dual
citizens we have large numbers of dual
citizens in this country how it applied
to all those people in Iraq and
elsewhere who'd helped American troops
there was so little if any vetting with
the people who have the expertise in
this area and then when the president
announced that he said well things are
going nicely well at that point there
there were numerous people were held out
the people he also said who needed to
know we're told well clearly that wasn't
the case because the people who are
they're trying to make decisions as to
whether who could come in had no idea no
guidance at all he has lately a
troublesome thing he has always said on
foreign policy they won't know they
being a you know big cattle umbrella
term for whoever it is out there that we
might be taking an action against with
lyst part of that was him who's this
Donald Trump deciding to take his first
sort of presidential step that would
blind side some countries that may be
aggressors well the irony is that they
were already told in the campaign by
Trump himself as a candidate that he was
going to restrict the inflow of Muslims
he was going to have extreme betting so
this was signaled in advance the notion
they had to do it very quickly to avoid
people coming in before the deadline
really is an odd thing to say when they
were told in advance by him and
specifically he was going to do these
kinds of things and I don't think that
it was well understood by anyone who was
actually writing this what the
implications of this were going to be if
we take more time to think it through
and get the input of experts in the
government and there are many experts I
worked on
this I was in the middle east i know a
lot about this but many many people who
are there now know a lot about it they
could have been consulted and a lot of
these problems pretty the very painful
humanitarian impact on a lot of people
do you make it avoided what do you make
of the choice of countries and the
choice of countries that are not on the
list so you know it's not just the
current administration that is picking
if you like on these countries it's been
not just one but two previous
administrations so Democrat and
Republican there's no political bias
here or is there well I think the
difference is that he referred to or his
spokesman referred to the Obama
administration coming up with these
countries list of seven but they were
identified as countries where there was
terrorism going on there was never a
utilization of that definition of that
characterization to make the kind of
sleeping restrictions on immigration
that have been made in this policy that
the president has just announced and I
think they really need when they're
making complicated decisions first of
all take their time and not rush it
second get the experts who were on the
government who can give them some sense
of the impact of this and really have a
feel for the details of American policy
and so before they change it they really
need to understand it understand all the
implications the idea that this can be
done so yes it created chaos but
nevertheless it stopped people from
getting into country and leaving the
country it really did you know present
if you like what I'm sure the president
saw as strength is that what you think
are our allies and non allies abroad
think of it as strength or weakness I
think the president has obviously
indicated his strong desire to be
tougher in terms of vetting people who
are coming in
that that's something that he has legal
authority in numerous areas to take
action to do to strengthen our
immigration policies but the key is how
do you do this does it look strong to
come up with a policy that is so
confusing we're so few people seem to
understand the implications of the
policy even the chief of staff of the
White House didn't quite know whether it
applied to green of card holders it
didn't this if he wants to present
strength he also has to demonstrate some
degree of capability to put forward a
policy that is understandable where the
rationale is clear that people can
implement it in an effective way putting
the policy forward that it is not
understood and is confusing and is not
implemented really doesn't project
strength he can do a number of things
but he has to do them in a more
effective way in a way that clarifies
rather than confuses the whole process